Everything in the real world
is being recreated
in the virtual world.
The metaverse.
The metaverse,
a persistent digital universe
that mirrors our world,
but is becoming as diverse
and awe-inspiring
as the natural world.
And you'll be able to do everything
you do in the real world
in the virtual world,
and more.
In the real world,
you can walk into a gallery,
buy a one-of-a-kind artwork that is signed
and authenticated as original,
take it home,
put it on the wall, enjoy it,
show it to your friends;
it might even be an investment.
The artwork becomes part of your story
and adds meaning to your life.
It marks a time and a feeling for you.
Now, we can have the exact same experience
in virtual galleries, with digital art.
While this might seem
like an obscure niche on the internet,
let's take a look at a recent auction sale
that you might have heard of.
In March of 2021,
the major auction house Christie's
sold a purely digital artwork
by an artist named Beeple
for 69 million dollars in cryptocurrency.
The auction, the artwork
and the currency was virtual,
but the transaction was very real.
But who can afford a Beeple?
Don't worry,
there are lots of artists
creating digital art
and conceptualizing brand new art forms
that you can afford.
I direct Media Entrepreneurship
and Innovation
at the Creative Media Industries Institute
at Georgia State University,
and our students are building
the metaverse as I speak.
We imagine a future where the students
and all digital artists
are able to continue building
new visions and new worlds --
basically, a better internet --
and can make a living while doing so.
The revolutionary instrument
that allowed for a digital file
to be sold as a unique artwork
for 69 million dollars
is the same tool that will allow
our students to make livings
as freelance creators.
There is a paradigm shift happening
that is turning the world
of content creation
and its financial rewards on its head.
Gone are the days of the internet
being a giant copying machine,
of intermediaries taking
a larger cut than the creators,
and of artists not receiving royalties.
This new automated tool
that allows for guaranteed proof
of origination and ownership
of music, videos, images and even text
is called an NFT:
non-fungible token.
The NFT is allowing everyone
to own their own data,
starting with art,
and there is a hope
that it will revolutionize
how value is created online
and how digital labor is monetized.
So the eternal question:
What is an NFT?
Simply put,
it is a permanent tracking device
that proves ownership of a digital file,
somewhat similar to the way
that you can chip a pet
to identify it as yours if it runs away,
an NFT is a cryptographic token
connected to a digital asset
to preserve ownership rights
in the metaverse.
Non-fungible means "not exchangeable."
Most things in the real world
are non-fungible,
because most physical objects are unique
and can't be traded one for one.
There is no painting, pet or person
that is exactly equivalent to another.
Money, on the other hand,
is one of the few items that is fungible,
meaning one dollar is equivalent
to another dollar
and one Bitcoin is equivalent
to another Bitcoin.
The underlying decentralized technology
that enabled digital currencies
such as Bitcoin
is blockchain.
Blockchain prevents digital money
from being duplicated or hacked,
and it removes the need
for a centralized authority,
such as a bank,
to validate transactions.
And like Bitcoin, the record
of ownership of an NFT
is kept in a public database
on the internet
that is maintained
by millions of computers
that keep track, via consensus,
of all content origination
and transactions.
At the Blockchain Lab
at Georgia State University,
we study how to monetize creative labor
using blockchains and other
decentralized ledger technologies.
I believe that this technology
in the form of NFTs
has the potential to humanize the internet
and to create an equitable foundation
for its next phase: the metaverse.
This decentralized business model
gives financial power back to the creators
and reduces the power
of the broker, the middleman
and even social media platforms.
Amy Rader is a fine artist in Atlanta
who shows in traditional galleries.
She created her first NFT
so that she could expand
to an online audience
and to add a new revenue stream
to increase her income.
Here's a Greg Mike mural.
If you're from Atlanta,
you have probably seen
some of his work on walls and buildings.
Street art is not permanent,
so how will an important
cultural icon like Greg Mike
utilize this new creative economy?
He is using the unique qualities
of NFTs to innovate
and to collaborate
with other artists and musicians
and connect with fans on the internet.
This way, his work will live on,
and he can take the proceeds
from the sales and resales
and continue creating his art.
Musicians can also capture
their true value
using NFTs.
Atlanta music producer Dallas Austin
is allowing fans to collect
memorabilia of his great moments
in music history,
similar to the way that NBA Top Shot
is allowing basketball fans to collect
historical replays as NFTs.
In the metaverse,
humans are represented as avatars.
An eight-year-old probably knows,
but did you know that you can buy
clothes for your avatar?
This is Kadine James.
She is leading the way in digital fashion
that can only be worn
in the virtual world.
Today, Gucci sells sneakers
that only exist in the virtual world,
and you can never wear them,
but your avatar can.
Alternatively,
you can use augmented reality
to overlay virtual sneakers
onto your in-real-life feet.
And because of NFTs,
anyone, not just well-known
companies like Gucci,
can create digital fashion to be bought,
sold and worn in games,
online platforms
and even in avatar fashion shows.
Take the pioneer 18-year-old FEWOCiOUS,
who was way ahead of Gucci,
with his crypto art and digital sneakers.
The use of augmented
and virtual-reality fashion
is becoming mainstream,
but because NFTs as art
and collectibles are so new,
the predictions are too volatile
for anyone to make.
But it is a sign that heavy hitters
like Mark Cuban and Snoop Dogg
are investing heavily.
This is the new frontier
for artists and their fans.
And just like in the real world,
and artist can sell a one-of-a-kind piece,
make limited editions
to control for scarcity,
show in art galleries and market places.
But with NFTs,
you can also sell directly to your buyer
without an intermediary,
collect royalties on all future resales,
expand your audience
to the entire internet,
show in virtual galleries
and virtual worlds
and sell 3D objects and clothes
to virtual humans.
OK, so how does this work,
and how do you get involved as an artist?
Your artwork is a digital file.
To protect this file
and capture the value
of your labor in perpetuity,
you go to a digital goods
marketplace and "mint" it,
meaning you register your work as a token,
for a fee, on the blockchain.
It will contain a signature, time stamp,
and any rules around its resale.
Once you’ve minted your work
and you want to sell it,
you connect with your community
and let them know
that your NFT has "dropped,"
meaning it is for sale.
It is important to note
that all the same rules
that make for good art and business
apply in the virtual world:
a strong connection to your followers,
an authentic or compelling story
and consistent output and work ethic.
So who will buy your art,
or how do you get involved as a collector?
Buyers go to the same
marketplaces that artists use.
There, you look for art
that you appreciate
and artists you want
a direct connection with.
Some people invest because the artwork
resonates with them,
or they recognize great talent,
or they see a potential for that artist
to play a significant part in history.
Once purchased directly from the artist,
you store your NFTs
in your digital wallet.
From there,
you can show on screens
and online marketplaces,
or in galleries, such as RareRooms,
a blockchain innovation
by Atlanta's GigLabs.
And with NFTs, a buyer knows
their art is fair trade,
transactions are transparent,
and the ecosystem is equitable.
The metaverse is a place
where we will spend
more and more of our lives.
Who builds it, who owns it
and how it is built
will determine what this world becomes.
But just like the real world,
the metaverse is very complex,
and there are many problems
yet to be solved.
And that is where you come in.
You are the future,
a digital citizen
whose responsibility it is
to be a good steward to the metaverse,
making sure that it is diverse, equitable,
accessible and sustainable.
This is just the beginning
of the decentralized movement.
NFTs will revolutionize
most online industries,
but it is starting
with the creative economy.
While nothing in this talk
is financial advice,
it is definitely educational
encouragement.
And why not start learning through art?
Jump in.
We need you.
I would like to thank the artists
who provided the art for this talk,
all of which are embedded
in the blockchain
as NFTs, non-fungible tokens.